nicht nur herr professor doktor karl
lauterbach ist also ein long beach
phänomen nicht nur er bläst als würde
die backen auf und schlägt auf die panik
trompete und bläst also die tuba der
angst nein es gibt leider gottes auch
ein team lauterbach besonders bei den
gesundheitsministern wie sie heute
getagt haben er steht nicht allein auf
weiter flur genauso starke panische
angst getriebenen machtbewusste töne
stimmen beispielsweise die
gesundheitsminister von baden
württemberg und von bayern an einen
grünen politiker und ein csu politiker
es gibt neue vorschläge auf dem tisch
von bayern von baden württemberg von
hessen vielleicht auch von thüringen zum
einen der instrumentenkasten soll
nachgeschärft werden also der
instrumentenkasten ist er ein folter
kasten zweig sind wieder drin sein 3g
masken tragepflicht
abstandsgebot
versammlungsverbote etc das heißt man
arbeitet schon vor ohne die evaluation
zu kennen und sogar der alte gassenhauer
kommt aus der geisterbahn zurück herr
mit der impfpflicht ab 60